i heard that benji had a date and the
date was so freaked out
you know like he finds these women on
these apps and i saw benji's picture
that he sent to these women
he has a dog he holds the dog over half
his face
oh my goodness this is like if he was a
missing person you'd never
find him you can't see him and what's
going on with your lips like
um are your lips dry or something man
there's something going on
you're all white and you're wiping them
with your hand
you see that it's almost like he has no
lips i think they got erased
what are you talking about i don't know
you look weird i think i have lips but
maybe you brush your teeth in the
morning i was just brushing
wait when you're talking about me yeah
maybe that's it like morning crap
all over his mouth but anyway the
picture you send you cover your whole
face with the dog
he literally got to the door and the
woman just said get out of here
i'd start walking down the street where
i'm going to meet her and i see this
girl like
like like shaking your head and looking
horrified like
i'm waving and i get in front of her and
she's like this is not good
you are you are not the man for me what
is she foreign
i guess she's russian or something like
that she was that direct huh was that so
cruel
it was almost like in a daze of
upsetness
i said to her hey you know i totally
appreciate this because
i i you know rather not waste my time i
appreciate this
no i was i i was expecting man with dog
attached to his face that's what i like
well that's what she said
she goes you know you looked good in
pictures
and and she was but picture was
deceiving you had like dog was covering
your face
when's the last time you got laid from
the zaps there's an embarrassing thing
like there was a
woman i dated a couple times
and we had a nice thing embarrassing
yeah everything's an incident
yeah she told me she was gay
yeah you might want to look what is she
doing she was gay and then she was
really sure after a couple of dates with
you you're being kind i think it was she
was totally straight and then became gay
after dating benji
but she still wanted like she liked the
idea of me
giving her like a massage and stuff i
don't know about these dating apps it
sounds like
a place where you go to get your ego
just completely demolished would you
stop wiping your lips with your hand
it's
so gross you want a tip about going out
with a girl you got this move where
you're constantly wiping your lips
you just did it again and it's vile okay
so i was drinking water and some water
dribbled and so i just
i did well maybe learn to drink water
without dribbling and then you you're
taking you
really don't wipe at all when you drink
here's what happens when i drink water
that's it i'm done i i
you well i wipe my lips with my arm
when i drink water are you high let me
try try to drink the water without
wiping your lips
[ __ ] guy man
there you go like i feel dripping down i
really want to get it but maybe practice
drinking water before your next date
robin just watched you drink and wipe
your lips and now she's a lesbian
you know what you ought to get like you
ever see little kids have a sippy cup
that's what you need
a sippy cup by the way howard do you
have a toothbrush sitting next to you
no you brush your teeth without a sink
it's it's back there but
i i uh i was eating and i knew
you were i heard you were talking about
me and i
i wanted to just brush real quick to get
the food out of my teeth
what was he talking about all right you
know what i'm done
all right thanks benji bye i know you're
almost done with benji
i just remembered didn't last year benji
tell a story about how he went on a date
and when he showed up the woman suddenly
realized that her son had been in a bad
accident she had to leave
yeah she said he he got in a car wreck
the day before
he was in the hospital she had to go
visit well he wanted to check on her
robin let me ask you
how many horrible experiences do you
have to have before you stop going on
dating apps i mean
what's that quit dating they don't even
think of good lies for benji
i'm sorry but i can't go on the date my
son
went into this thing called a
transponder he's turning into a fly he's
half
human half fly that sounds bad
benji i have to leave the date my son
has a doll named chucky and he came to
life and he's chasing him around the
house and he just called me